now the Democrats have stopped
encouraging race riots and other mass
gatherings that are convenient for their
political agenda well you know we still
got three months to a presidential
election so they are locking down again
that is what is happening in my own
state here of California the science has
not changed but the politics has here is
our American Psycho governor governor
Newsom announcing in perfect gibberish
the reason for the new lockdown based on
the trend lines based on the data based
on the science to modify our stay at
home order subsequently meaning not on
opened economy or off shutdown but a
dimmer switch looking at conditions
throughout the nation's most populous
state as they present themselves as
those trend lines become points of
concern before they invariably become
headlines it's a consequence of increase
in positivity rate increase in
hospitalizations and icy use based upon
the predicate this foundation that we
laid on utilizing a dimmer switch on the
predicate of the dimmer switch of the
trend lines and the data and the science
and the and the have you ever heard more
gobbledygook in your life have you ever
heard a politician trying to pretend
that he's not talking about politics in
a more ridiculous manner I mean that
basically describes the entire left's
approach to our political regime at this
point but he's trying to put onto
science that which remains in the realm
of politics and he doesn't do a very
convincing job of it because the science
hasn't changed at all his convenient
political actions have he finally gets
to the meat of the lockdown what is
going to happen today we are announcing
additional statewide actions as it
relates to our stay at home order here
in the state of California we are now
effectively rather effective today
requiring all counties to close their
indoor activities their indoor
operations in the following sectors
restaurants wineries tasting rooms
movie theaters family entertainment
centers zoos and museums card rooms and
the shuttering of all bars this is in
every county in the state of California
so that's in every county he chooses
some arbitrary industries to shut down
but then the Devils in the details in
some counties that are on the official
monitoring list it's going to be much
more onerous using me shutting down
businesses much more intensely he's
going to be shutting down houses of
worship and it turns out that those
select counties are most of the counties
in California more than 50% of them
which hold more than 80% of the
California residents let me be clear
there is no scientific argument for
locking down again this is strictly
political our opponents say that we
don't get science I think they don't get
the politics that their leaders get the
politics the followers do not they don't
get the politics they don't get the
science either we'll get into both I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Noel's show
[Music]
so that sophisticated virus that knows
to only infect the conservative
gatherings but not infect the leftist
gatherings well now they don't have any
leftist mass gatherings because the
riots are over so everybody's got a
lockdown again it's such a brilliant
virus there's a big battle going on a
big battle going on over in particular
reopening the schools the outcome of
that battle we talked about yesterday
how it's in the little things that the
rock begins that will dictate a lot of
what we see for the next 3-4 months
until the presidential election first
though I've got to get to the question
for today which is what should be the
new name for the Washington Redskins
another ridiculous distraction that we
have heard announce the Washington
Redskins football team will be renamed
the best comment from yesterday by the
way we were we were trying to figure out
what institution is going to be renamed
next and it's so obvious it's gonna be
the Men's Wearhouse because not only is
retail shopping shut down right now and
not only is a retail canceled but men
are canceled too so it's gonna have to
be their warehouse or Z warehouses or
warehouse so let me know your thoughts
on the Redskins in the comment section
also got to thank our friends over at
first leaf you know how much I love
drinking high quality wine particularly
at a good and reasonable price and you
know how much I have this fear this fear
that you're at home maybe you've
experienced this you're finishing a
delicious glass of wine and just as
you're about to pour know you reach out
you realize there's no backup bottle
that's called no vino phobia it's the
fear of running out of wine well thanks
to first leaf I get personalized boxes
of wine shipped right to my door here is
how you can get incredible wine without
leaving the comfort of your home you
start by taking a quick quiz to assess
your wine drinking preferences then
first leaf sends you six expertly picked
bottles of wine based on your answers
they have a hundred percent satisfaction
guarantee and what I love about it is
they push the buttons of your taste belt
so sometimes there's some wines I didn't
even know that I liked the more you use
it the more you rate the wines the
better the selection becomes I love
these guys after my freebie is that they
sent me
I kept son I kept signing up I kept
paying it's so great sign up today get
six bottles of wine for only twenty nine
ninety five plus free shipping
just go to try first leaf comm slash
Knowles that is six bottles of wine for
only 2995 at try first leaf dot-com
slash Knowles go check it out now
there's gonna be this big issue the big
fight even as the Democratic states are
trying to lock down again and some
squishy Republicans follow them the big
battle is going to be over the schools
because whether or not we reopen the
schools is going to dictate a fair bit
about our economy it's gonna dictate how
much government spending is gonna have
to be injected back into the economy
because for a lot of parents they need
the schools to look after their kids
they rely on it so even if some schools
like in New York for instance they say
they're gonna reopen maybe a couple days
a week but then keep the kids home a few
days a week
that's not going to work for parents and
parents in New York by the way work you
have to work it's a very expensive city
so what is going to happen people are
going to be forced out of work even
longer and it would seem to me that is
what the object is of this second
lockdown so we talked to the medical
scientists we talked to the doctors
is it safe to reopen the schools clearly
the mainstream media want that answer to
be no and yet on MSNBC they asked number
of doctors and they got a scientifically
correct but politically inconvenient
answer would you let your kids go back
to school I will my kids are looking
forward to it yes period absolutely
absolutely
as much as I can hesitation yes I have
no concerns about sending my child to
school in the fall I would my kids go
back to school dr. John Torres NBC News
they all said yes so you got the report
from the straight reporter then it cuts
back to the anchor at MSNBC looking
furious they all have they all say yes
so they will send their kids back to
school and let the economy reopen and
possibly reelect the orange man that is
terrible the left relies on science when
it's convenient for them when the
experts back them up oh they ignore
science when it's not going to be we
obviously see this on the science
of sex they don't care a lot about
science when they're talking about 56
imaginary genders they don't care a lot
about science when they pretend that
babies are not really people but they
try to rely on science when some of the
public health experts give them what
they want politically so politically
speaking not the public health experts
politically they're trying to shut down
the schools the teachers union in Los
Angeles shows you how political this has
gotten so the union is demanding you
know the teachers unions have caused so
much trouble throughout this country but
especially in places like New York in
California well in Los Angeles the
teachers union is demanding before they
agreed to allow the schools to reopen
they're demanding that all students must
be tested for kovat 19 in the weeks
prior to returning to school okay fine
whatever
I guess we're okay with that right that
seems relatively reasonable next next
one all students must take weekly kovat
19 tests seems kind of like overkill but
okay fine it's still at least focused on
the virus these teachers are a little
bit wacky but we already knew that okay
fine let's say we give into that one
then the students must wear door-to-door
mandatory face masks at all times well
that's not going to work well first of
all that's absurd that you think that
school kids are gonna sit on a bus with
that stupid mask on second of all what
are they gonna they're gonna eat in the
cafeteria they're gonna have their mask
on and slip it through underneath the
mask I don't think so
or at recess they're going to do that or
at all no that's not going to happen but
even that third third request I see or
demand rather the teachers aren't
requesting but I see how it relates to
the virus but they have other demands
the Union does not want to reopen the
schools from the virus until there is a
moratorium on charter schools so good
schools that threaten their cushy jobs
and their educational failures and give
kids a better education the Union
teachers union doesn't want to reopen
schools until the police are defunded
why
I don't know what does that have to do
with growing virus absolutely nothing
they don't want to reopen the schools
until they have Medicare for all
so these freaking teachers are not
allowing their students to be educated
probably ever judging by the demands
they're making but they're not even
allowing the facade of Education the
schools to reopen until we have
socialist medicine they don't want to
reopen the schools until we have a
wealth tax so not not just an income tax
not just raising taxes and the money you
earn but actually just going into your
bank account stealing the money that
you've already paid taxes on and until
there is a federal bailout for I know I
guess for everybody for California for
Los Angeles for the schools that's not
about the virus they are using the virus
they are exploiting the virus whatever
threat the virus poses which would
appear to have been dramatically
overhyped they are using that to push
for a radical agenda the likes of which
we have rarely seen in this country this
gets to a point that I wish the left and
I wish many conservatives could get
through their skulls there is no
scientific basis for a second lockdown
what was the lockdown for the lockdown
was 15 days to slow the spread how long
has it been now we're at something like
130 days why did we want to slow the
spread so that we didn't overwhelm the
hospital system
we never did we never came close not
even in New York not even in Los Angeles
nowhere the predictions were not correct
the models were not correct
we the curve was flattened but people
are still going to get it now they now
that they transferred that from flatten
the curve to find a cure but now it
seems we have found a cure dr. pouchy
said this just a while ago but the
vaccine at the rosiest predictions is
going to be 70% effective and that the
rosiest predictions 70% of people are
going to get it which means we won't get
hurt immunity which means all of this
was for nothing we won't have a cure
people will still have to get it we will
still have to go outside
there is no way that a lockdown is going
to stop the virus there is no way that a
mask is going to stop the virus the
virus is going to be what the virus is
going to be actually the fact of the
second lockdown is showing us how futile
it is to try to completely eradicate
this thing it's not going away it's
going to keep coming back the only
purpose that this could serve is
political we have done every single
thing possible to fix the problem
medically actually our our establishment
our Public Health and political
establishment has done many things to
try to prolong the problem medically for
one reason or in one example of this by
suppressing hydroxychloroquine which was
an early treatment for the virus that
President Trump touted that then you saw
some fraudulent paper is published
talking about how hydroxi Clark and was
really dangerous and it hastened death
now of course those papers got retracted
but nobody reads the retractions they
only read the headlines which the
mainstream media push counterproductive
stuff if your goal is to slow down the
virus give the public back its
confidence and reopen but they don't
want to do that they don't want to
reopen they want to keep you locked down
until November other countries are
opening up again do you know why because
they don't have a presidential election
in November and their establishment is
not willing to ruin people's lives
prevent people from being with their
loved ones while they die prevent people
from having jobs prevent people from
having a livelihood just to kick out
their political opponent what we are
saying here is that the lockdown is not
scientific it's entirely political the
Left accuses us of not understanding the
science well I've just described the
science I've described the science I
think better than most of the scientific
experts because the scientific experts
have been completely wrong the whole
time and even a layman like we
conservatives is able to predict it
better to see it better
regular old Joe on the street we found
one well we'll play that in just a
moment has a better record on this virus
than the media scientific political
establishment it's not that the right
does not understand the science here
it's
the left at least the followers the
rank-and-file don't understand the
politics they don't understand how the
left has perverted science for the last
50 years at least - really for the last
150 years to push their political agenda
because politics you know is when we all
just talk and debate things and you know
you've got you've got eternal questions
justice and mercy well how are we going
to resolve those two things we're going
to talk to our fellow citizens and
debate them what the left pretends is
that there is a clear science of
politics and what they want is what they
should get don't you guys think it's a
little coincidental that the way to
solve the coronavirus problem as a
matter of public policy is exactly the
way to solve the global warming problem
massive redistribution of wealth massive
federal subsidies massive jobs program
constricting the rights of people don't
you isn't that a little weird that you
would expect to issues that are so
different a Chinese virus and the polar
ice caps melting or the ozone layer
being depleted you expect those problems
to have different solutions and yet for
the left it's always the same one
different different verse same as the
first this is it
you need to stand against this this is
the political fight of your age and you
might like to soothe yourself into
thinking that it's all it's just about
the science it's not this is about
politics we will look back on this
number of years and realize the
political consequence of this and for
those of us who call ourselves
conservatives or who call ourselves
old-school liberals you know who just
want to go back to normal this is the
time to take a stand if you don't take a
stand now you're very likely not going
to have the opportunity because the
effect of this is not just on the
economy it's not just on the election
people are dying out there
the crime surges are through the roof
people are getting killed in the streets
and our Democratic leaders are
gaslighting us they're pretending us
it's not even happening
AOC is the most egregious offender we'll
get to that in a second first though I
got to thank our friends over at
expressvpn you got to talk about your
internet freedom social media companies
now get to decide what is suitable for
all those sensitive people among us they
censor whatever they don't like well
shouldn't
you be the one to decide what you want
to read or watch not them here's one
thing you can control their access to
your data for that I use Express VPN I
rely on these guys the problem with big
tech companies is not only that they
censor what you read they also track
what you do online they track what
you're searching for the videos you
watch everything you click well
expressvpn encrypts 100% of your data to
protect you from hackers and internet
bad guys their software it takes with
just one minute to set up on your
computer or phone you tap one button
you're protected it's fabulous
it's really important to protect
yourself from bad actors just think
about just think about the kind of
people who have your data just think
about the kind of weird stuff you look
at online you know you open up that
incognito window and then you search for
I don't know things like the Michael
Nolt show I don't know what you look at
but you don't want big tech having men
why give them a free license to know
everything about you and then turn
around sell your information right now
to expressvpn comm / Michael visit my
special link you'll get an extra three
months for free
who doesn't like saving money exp ress
VPN comm / michael to protect your data
today when we look around at the very
tangible effects of this thing of this
lockdown and the fake science behind the
lockdown behind the second lockdown
obviously there is carnage out there we
just had the country on fire for a few
weeks and now because there's less in a
way of policing they've defunded the
police police are walking off the job
because they're being targeted by these
civil authorities crime is shooting
through the roof well a OC is not too
worried about that even in New York
where the bullets are flying she is
saying oh it's not it's don't worry
about the violent crime these are crimes
of necessity well let's think about it
do we think this has to do with the fact
that there's record unemployment in the
United States right now the fact that
people are at a level of economic
desperation that we have not seen since
the Great Recession maybe this has to do
with the fact that people aren't paying
their rent and are scared to pay their
rent and so they go out and they need to
feed their child and they don't
have money so you maybe have to you're
they're put in a position where they
feel like they either need to shoplift
some bread or go hungry that night
that's what it is this is Jean Valjean
this is lame miserable just trying to
get a loaf of bread to feed their kids
is that what's going on no I don't think
so as Caitlyn Flanagan pointed out on
Twitter the the uptick in crime isn't
stealing a loaf of bread it's 11 dead
New Yorkers just over the weekend they
were not they were not killing the the
bread store owners so they could grab
the bread this is sick violent crime so
people pointed this out these are not
crimes of necessity these are crimes of
of
violent thug criminals and asu's
responses Republicans are all upset that
I'm connecting the dots between poverty
and crime well I know most of them have
an experienced or seeing these issues
firsthand but I have this may be hard
for them to admit but poverty and crime
are highly linked both violent and
nonviolent alike I would like to take
this moment to remind you all that a OC
is a fraud who did not grow up in the
Bronx like she pretends to she grew up
in the wealthier town next to my already
wealthy town in Westchester at that time
one of the wealthiest counties in the
United States she is not Jenny from the
block she grew up in beautiful Yorktown
Heights where deer are prancing through
the hills she went to a very good high
school and a very expensive private
college she does not know what what this
this growing up in poverty and the
you're forced to steal a loaf of bread
is like nowhere near it total fraud just
like the whole rest of the left which
talks about this stuff the premise here
is that the cause of crime is not the
evil that is lurking in man's heart all
of man's heart because we're falling
creatures the cause of crime is society
there's something broken in the system
and it all boils down by the way to
money so if you just inject a little bit
more money into certain communities if
you just give some people money they
will not commit crimes all of our
experience of human history contradicts
this very stupid idea and this very
stupid understanding of human nature but
that's her belief and frankly she's
getting a lot of support these
from the activists who have been burning
down the country who also shared that
premise they are a valid trained
Marxists she's getting that given to her
she's getting that support from leftist
Democratic politicians people sitting in
Congress her colleagues in Congress
major Democratic candidates and she's
even getting it from some squishy
Republicans who want to go along with
all of this so that no one criticizes
them or calls them dumb or says that
they don't understand the science that
they themselves have absolutely no
credibility on whatsoever the science by
the way which contradicts itself almost
every single day and then they pretend
that they never issued any other
guidance the Republicans are giving in
conservatives are giving in here you
know fortunately Trump is held pretty
strong on this whole thing for now but
they're just wearing us down wearing us
down wearing us down and because I think
sometimes we ourselves don't understand
the politics luckily Haley mcenany does
you know there are there are a few
really well-placed people here and
Kaylee mackaninee is just incredibly
good at her job so White House press
secretary comes out she is asked
questions about this AOC point on crimes
of necessity she doesn't give it one
moment's acceptance she smacks it down
we know that in Los Angeles when they
announced they would be defunding their
Police Department by 150 million they
basically immediately after saw 250%
increase in homicides when you have
people out there like representative
Ilhan omar's saying we have to
completely dismantle the police and
police our cancer this is not how we
should be talking about our heroes it's
not you listen to her words there she
refers to our police officers the people
who protect us as heroes this is what
you've got to do I would say there were
three categories here the first one is
the left which says that cops are racist
bigoted killers then there's Kaylee
Makani calling them heroes and then
there are the damned squishes not worth
anything who come out there and they say
well
look III think the result there are a
lot of bad police and the police need to
be reformed but just some of them are
good and they're trying to play both
sides and it doesn't work you're not
seeing clearly if you stand in the
middle of the road you're going to get
hit by a truck there is no evidence at a
national level that the police need to
be seriously reformed we've gone through
the numbers how many unarmed black men
were killed by cops last year and by the
way unarmed doesn't mean not dangerous
unarmed does not mean that the killing
wasn't justified share have many 9990
know nine nine single digits and how
many of those killings were justified if
you go you can go through them one by
one many of them were justified killings
were the guys attacking the cops she
realizes that this battle has to be
fought on clear terms you see it and in
the question of the lockdowns well maybe
it can't hurt to shut down the economy
again without really having an objective
in mind because we can't cure the virus
and we're not going to totally stop its
spread and we're not going to get hurt
immunity but let's just shut down
because people really seem to want us to
shut down and I don't want to be called
dumb or hateful or accused of killing
granny and I know that they changed
their tune and they said it was
perfectly fine to gather in large groups
when they were tearing down George
Washington but and now it's different
but hey look that's just the left hey
guys let's just meet in the middle let's
come on let's have it there's no meeting
in the middle on this there's no meeting
in this is the battle so pick a side or
don't remain neutral but history doesn't
look very kindly on those who remain
neutral during times of great moral
questions then Kaylee mackaninee because
she is so good at this
realizes that you can't just talk
general you can't can't just talk about
why a Aussies point is abstractly wrong
she hones in on the daughters the
families of these cops who have been
killed in the line of work after being
vilified by the left and deprived of
their own protection from the civil
authority this weekend in New York you
see a one-year-old killed in a stroller
his name was devel Gardner jr. and
one-year old will be in our prayers not
only that you see officers Garza and
Chavez and to your question about how we
should talk about the police and defund
the police movement the president stands
against the two officers ambushed this
weekend one of them officer Chavez his
daughter wrote a very touching tribute
online she said words cannot describe
the pain I'm in but I'm glad my dad is
at peace
you were an amazing man and anyone who
ever came across you knew that I'm going
to miss you so much you died doing what
you love most you died a hero
and those touching words were written by
Savannah Chavez and I know she received
vile and outrageous comments online that
were absolutely atrocious for a touching
sentiment to her dad I want to Savannah
to know your dad is a hero his Police
Department should never be defunded
because most of our police officers are
good hard-working men and women and
heroes much like Savannah's dad we'll be
praying for you Savannah
thank you I love that clarification
there at the end she goes I want you to
know unless it wasn't clear what I was
saying before I want you to know your
dad as a hero the difference between
political campaigns election years tough
political times and oh I don't know
lunch around the Academy is in the
latter when you're just kind of
spitballing and discussing political
ideas there can be a whole lot of nuance
a whole lot of complexity a lot of well
yeah give-and-take sure when you're in a
political campaign you've got to be
clear about what you think and what your
objectives are because you need to
follow up these ideas with action and a
lot of people in this country believe
that this lockdown is just the result of
an academic discussion of science it's
not the science is not leading the
politics the politics is leading the
science because this is an election year
so speak clearly know what this is about
this is not the time to bat around ideas
and see what happens this is this has
stark consequences and it will have very
stark consequences for our country
if we let every day that the second
lockdown goes on Joe Biden's chances of
getting elected increase substantially
every day that that guy who can't string
two words together is allowed to sit in
his basement rather than campaign
his chances of winning increase every
day that kids are not sent back to
school and their parents very likely are
not able to go back to work Joe Biden's
chances of winning increased
substantially every day that a
Republican politician puts on a mask
needlessly in public Joe Biden's chances
of winning increase substantially
because you buy into his premises it's
amazing that the right is so bad at
politics it's amazing that they don't
understand what's happening to them
maybe it's because the right is a little
less deceptive about the whole thing
because we actually tell people what we
think and sometimes those views are not
popular in the moment but we we tell
them what we think anyway we don't we
don't speak in in the sort of
mealy-mouthed language that you get from
somebody like Joe Biden who wants to
play all sides all the time but this is
the battle and we should at least speak
clearly about what is really going on as
a matter of that campaign we will get to
the good news on the virus that is not
being reported because you're hearing a
lot of bad news but all the bad news is
just a cover for all the very good news
we'll get to that in one second first I
got to thank you I gotta thank you for
going over to Apple podcasts and
subscribing to the Michael Noel's show
and leaving five star reviews we really
appreciate that you can check out my
exclusive content that we post there for
instance my interview with Mark
McCluskey the the st. Louis gun guy who
was the guy wearing that pink polo shirt
and the white chinos who is just a hero
to all Americans who want to defend
themselves he broke some news actually
in an interview the other day and we've
got some news to break with him today
also if you're not already a daily wire
member consider getting a reader's pass
at Daley wire.com it's just 99 cents a
month you get access to our mobile app
articles ad free and access to exclusive
editorials go to daily wire com sign up
for just a buck and then buy Ben's book
you know there's a lot of craziness
going on journalism is collapsing and
that's just the sort of thing that Ben
is talking about in his book how to
destroy America in three easy steps you
can pre-order your signed copy today at
Daley wire.com slash Ben we'll be right
back with a lot more
let's delve in for just a moment into
the actual science of the coronavirus we
hear cases skyrocketing we hear a lot of
silly arguments for the lockdowns what
about the deaths
how are the we notice they don't talk
about the deaths too much they only talk
about the the diagnosis because
obviously we're testing more and more
people are going into the hospital and
perhaps more people are coming down with
it but the death rate is lower than we
thought New York City once the epicenter
of coronavirus on Sunday reported for
the first time in months since the
beginning of this epidemic reported no
deaths from coronavirus zero zero now
they tell us don't get excited don't get
happy it's gonna get much worse be
afraid be very afraid stay in your home
but just just think about that if you if
you were just to close your eyes listen
to the mainstream media talking about
coronavirus particularly in New York
which was the hardest yet would you
imagine that the reality of that is that
on Saturday and being reported Sunday
not one single person in the city died
from the virus particularly given how
lakhs they are in the way that they are
classifying these deaths but if you die
with coronavirus you are said to have
died of coronavirus you could be 97
years old and die of pneumonia but you
be you you would be put down as dying
from coronavirus some people have been
shot actually shot with guns but they
have been classified as coronavirus
debts and not one in New York on
Saturday that is very good news but you
can't celebrate that good news you've
just got to focus on any bad news and if
there's no bad news you've got to make
it up another example here in California
people are not allowed to attend church
services indoors that's what governor
Newsom just said you're allowed to
vandalize churches but you're not
allowed to attend church services and
actually worship God and that a little
weird there we've seen some of the
attacks on the churches we know there
was the attack on that famous church st.
John's in Washington cops really did
nothing to stop that they were told to
stand down but this is happening all
over the place
churches in California New York
Massachusetts Florida all being attacked
all being set ablaze all being
vandalized major damage they suffered
some some were historic churches too a
man in Florida drove his vehicle into
the Queen of Peace Catholic Church as it
was preparing for morning Mass on
Saturday then poured gasoline in the
foyer and then set the building on fire
that's it before he drove off in LA the
the historic San Gabriel church which
has almost been around for a quarter of
a millennium was targeted in an arson
attack someone tried to set it on fire
in Boston a statue of the Virgin Mary
was set on fire and desecrated another
statue of the Virgin Mary was desecrated
on Sunday in New York City this stuff is
going on all over the place that's fine
no one seems to stop that and yet
governor knew some very very worried and
Winkley other other governors and
mayor's too very worried about people
actually going in and praying certainly
there's no science to that but there's
there's no political reasoning either if
you want to maintain order if you want
people to behave if you want to live in
a normal nice society but they don't
want that they don't want that what the
left in this country wants is chaos and
mayhem and destruction economic and
social and political until November 3rd
and then it's all gonna change mark my
words if Biden wins
heaven forfend that's all over frankly
even if Trump wins they're going to be
so deflated that it will start to trail
off too but certainly certainly if Biden
wins think about that backwards this is
you can set a church on fire but you
can't go pray you can walk up to
somebody's home with guns threaten their
lives and their property that's totally
fine you're a peaceful protester but if
you the homeowner take out your own gun
to defend your property you will be
arrested and indicted that's what the
McCluskey's in st. Louis believe is
about to happen they have heard rumors
around town that they are about to be
indicted and and other political figures
in st. Louis have suggested that as well
you know
there's a lot of misinformation on the
McCluskey's - we were told that the
McCloskey is the same louis gun couple
are actually democrats they're actually
support as a black lives matter i spoke
with mr. McClosky
and he said that that like so much else
during the riots and the mayhem and the
lockdowns and the virus all of which by
the way are very very related that as
well was fake news you know i want to
set the record straight on one thing
i've been reading a lot of reports about
me on the media some of whom have
accused me of being a democrat and i
have donated money to various candidates
particularly ones that were personal
friends of mine over the year but I've
been a lifelong Republican another thing
I'd like to clear up is that the media
reports me as being a supporter of the
black lives matter movement and I am
certainly not a black lives matter - my
understanding is a Marxist organization
opposed to everything I stand for
whatever thing I hold near and dear I do
stand for equal justice for all under
the law but that's got nothing to do
with this terrorist organization known
as black lives matter love that guy won
because he's correcting all that fake
news - because he defended his property
but three because he's just a guy right
he's not a super-duper expert he's not
an elected official he's not a man in a
jacket and a tie on the mainstream media
he's not wearing any jacket I he was
wearing a pink polo in white chinos just
a regular guy who is speaking more
common sense on what is going on right
now
then most other people that we look to
for guidance than we look to for
leadership this is happening all around
us I for one I've had enough of dr.
pouchy I've had enough of all the
SuperDuper scientific experts and I've
especially had enough of dr. pouchy dr.
pouchy has been wrong since the
beginning which is fine people get
things wrong
I'm not attributing malice to the guy
however he more than anyone in this
country has been vociferous in locking
down everything put your foot on the
accelerator don't take your foot off the
accelerator destroy the economy for what
15 days to slow the spread how many days
was that 115 days ago under 30 days ago
maybe longer I've had enough of that
there's no argument
left doctor fatty we played it on the
show yesterday who said don't wear masks
at the height of the virus he said
wearing masks is ridiculous it's stupid
don't do it now we all have to wear
masks I've just had enough I don't I'm
not saying he's a bad guy but he's been
wrong he's been worse than wrong his
advice has damage to the country enough
of him
fortunately it seems the president might
also agree with my assessment of the
exalted doctor foul Qi peace be upon him
he tweeted out a few few tweets over the
weekend that were oh I think these
tweets actually just came out yesterday
even better more urgent it's more likely
to be to continue now that we're pretty
critical of a foul Qi not by name but by
association Trump retweeted everyone is
lying the CDC media Democrats are
doctors not all but most though that we
are told to trust I think it's all about
the election and keeping the economy
from coming back which is about the
election I'm sick of it that's true
another post the Trump retweeted has so
much evidence yes scientific evidence
that schools should open this fall it's
a worldwide and it's overwhelming but no
yep also true and the final one Trump
tweeted retweeted said so based on dr.
Fatih and the Democrats I will need an
ID card to go shopping but not to vote
you see that last one the one that
actually names foul Chi it's not
explicitly a criticism it's a question
but it's a question that is absurd right
it's a question that in itself is a
criticism you're telling me I need an ID
to go buy a carton of milk but I don't
need one to exercise my most important
right as a citizen to choose my own
leaders that's good you know a lot of
times people say to about Trump take
away the Twitter to wake take away the
phones just let all of his advisers run
things I think he's been getting some
bad advice I don't have a whole lot of
respect for many of his advisers I have
respect for some of his advisers who
have been encouraging his good instincts
but the ones who have been forcing him
to waffle on this thing to change his
initial instincts on his handling of the
lockdown to give the left to their
premises
to seriously threaten his chance at
reelection I don't have a lot of respect
for them
I think Trump has had good instincts I
think Trump is much more in tune with
regular old everyday Americans then his
sophisticated advisors are who haven't
left Washington DC in several decades
and I think that Trump's got to follow
those instincts there was a guy who is a
video going around the Internet of a guy
who used rough language he talked it you
know I not that sort of thing we would
want to emulate necessarily but I think
what he was expressing is what a lot of
us are feeling right now which is he was
he was just shopping minding his own
business and in some stores now it's not
enough that you have to wear the mask
and I don't know perform all these weird
rituals you actually have to walk
following arrows through the store so
let's say you're walking you know you're
you walk past the the pasta aisle and
you get into the bread aisle but then
you realize oh wait I forgot I need some
spaghetti so you turn around you walk
back three feet they scream at you they
get so crazy all of these people who are
on such an hysterical edge from the
coronavirus alarmism so this woman
decides to start filming this guy for
now imagine that walking up to a
stranger and just filming them for no
reason and this guy goes off he reminds
us why increasingly it seems the laymen
are wiser than the experts take a
picture of me that make you feel better
why don't you get a life and that's
going around taking pictures mirrors
asked us all to wear masks and look at
you not wearing a mask oh dude it's a
political it's unbelievable now you have
accosted me in this store that I got to
wear you're gonna keep this up maybe
we'll get the police department what you
call 911 then yeah yeah another one out
of a tree now you're the monkey that has
it pay off in those knuckles
if I remove them evolution reading Bob
mister why don't you go back to where
you are you burning crosses are you
burning crosses great interaction
absolutely terrific it illustrates so
much of what we're seeing now which is
this guy is minding his own business
buying something in a store not a
costing anybody and some lunatic woman
to actually start filming him because
he's not performing the very specific
political rituals that we've been told
for the past few weeks we have to
perform but a few weeks ago those same
people who tell us we have to performant
oldest we shouldn't perform namely
wearing the masks walking in the right
directions and when he says lady you're
acting crazy this is not normal behavior
to go up to people and start filming
them because they're not shopping for
groceries in exactly the way that you
want this is crazy stuff what does she
says she goes you don't know science you
probably don't believe in evolution
you probably don't listen to what the
exalted dr. foul Chi you don't she she
loves a political attack that is cloaked
as science and that is what I presume
this woman is of the left I presume she
is a Democrat this is what her national
political leader leaders are doing all
the time and yet there is more wisdom in
this layman's gut than in all of the
pseudo scientific knowledge and
credentials of that crazy lady of the
left think about this there was a story
that came up a week or two ago though it
hasn't come up recently because it
didn't support the left-wing narrative
it's about a 24-year old black man who
was found hanging from a tree in
Southern California and the LA Sheriff's
Office said that this guy died from
suicide and all of the BLM rioters the
leadership suggested that this was a
lynching BLM the the the self-described
Marxists of BLM and the the crazed
leftists who support them
are convinced that lynchings happen in
the US all the time it's practically
1875 Alabama or South Carolina right now
in Southern California all all around
the country are all these lynchings any
normal person who saw that story
realized this guy died by suicide didn't
worry about it but they pushed and they
pushed and they push now we found out
they finally admitted it yesterday there
was no foul play it was a suicide well
what else do we know about this guy's
history we know he had a history of
mental illness we know that there were
prior reports of suicidal ideation we
know he had disclosed a plan to kill
himself prior to his death all according
to the sheriff's commander Chris marks
at a news conference we know that he
purchased from a local Dollar Tree a red
rope consistent with the one used in the
hanging very sad story that this guy
killed himself there was never any
evidence whatsoever that it was a
lynching but the left insists on pushing
that narrative why so that it could
further divide people so that it could
so that it could encourage the riots
which the scientific establishment was
more than happy to encourage because it
was advancing their political agenda you
remember that letter where they said
they sent out the letter it was over a
thousand public health scientists and
they public all the experts quote
unquote and they said that if you
protest the lockdowns that's bad it's
going to kill people and if you protest
for a BLM or or any other leftist cause
that's good that'll actually suppress
the spread of the virus ridiculous now
that now that those riots have abated
now that they're trying to push up the
the lockdowns again they're also back to
this idea that Donald Trump is a Nazi
was ridiculous article on the Internet
all of yesterday from USA Today was a
fact check over whether the Trump
campaign selling a t-shirt with Nazi
imagery now why do they call it Nazi
imagery because the Trump campaign was
selling a t-shirt with an eagle on it
you know an eagle like a symbol of
America very well-known symbol of
America well they said this is Nazi
imagery because the Nazis also had an
eagle it's one of their symbols so they
did the fact check the fact check
originally said this was true but it was
if you use an eagle you are a Nazi just
like they tried to redefine
the okay sign or you know the game where
you you put the okay sign out and then
you get punched in the arm if you look
at it we remember they tried to define
that as a Nazi symbol they tried to
redefine milk as a Nazi symbol it
defined frogs as a Nazis everything is a
Nazi symbol now including bald eagles
they've since updated it with an
editor's note store has been updated to
reflect further reporting and analysis
and the rating has been changed to
inconclusive it's not inconclusive it's
false
yeah if you use a bald eagle in American
political imagery that's not a Nazi
symbol that's an American symbol and it
has been for a long time but it but you
see it's it's to reflect further
reporting and analysis there's no
further analysis
they just got called out on their BS
there's no there's no further scientific
analysis that is causing Democratic
political leaders to do whatever they
want arbitrarily and defend it with the
gobbledygook of scientific speech we you
know we got some good news out of
Florida too on the science there's a guy
Alex Berenson has done a great job
covering the science of coronavirus you
know you if you just read the headlines
about Florida you would think you would
think the entire state is on death's
door right now you might say the entire
states on death's door because it's a
little bit of an older population people
people tend to go there to retire but
specifically because of the coronavirus
frankly you would think because of that
older population they would have been
absolutely decimated well you know
there's 70,000 new cases positive tests
for the virus do you know how many
people are now in the hospital because
of those 70,000 new cases 70,000 the
whole state 130 people have gone to the
hospital for that not a hunt nut out of
1300 130,000 130 more patients in ICU
beds statewide last week because of the
virus 45 deaths in one day in a state of
20 million people if we could have a
nice polite civilized calm scientific
discussion of the virus I'm sure it
would be very interesting
it's a novel virus we haven't seen this
one before similar to other viruses
we've had it's acting in ways that are
kind of interesting ways that confound
the models ways we might not have
predicted if we could have that
conversation I'm sure that would be
interesting in an academic sort of way
but that's not the conversation that
anybody is having the only conversation
that people are having right now is
political the leftist leaders understand
that perhaps the rank and file do not
but the leaders do and unfortunately the
right many people on the right too many
people on the right don't understand
just how political it is time is running
out folks we are living here in time and
space statues are toppling down in time
and space the economy is stagnating in
time and space and that presidential
election is getting closer and closer
and closer campaigns are about giving a
clear message giving a people a clear
choice and if they're right if the right
falls into this trap you know there was
Trump actually gave us an option
Trump was different than the other
candidates in 2016
Trump shook things up he stood tall he
stood differently one problem with
Republicans they always squished to the
left Trump gave us that choice but if he
keeps getting bad advice if he squishes
if he doesn't give us a choice if he
keeps moving over there if he grants
their premises then in this
extraordinary election year we are going
to we are going to be get wiped out by a
political strategy and we're not even
going to know it's political until it's
too late
make your choice don't stand in the
middle of the road that's our show we
got a lot more to get to we'll have to
do it tomorrow in the meantime I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael Nolt
show
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by Ben
Davies executive producer Jeremy Boren
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director pavel
madoski editor and associate producer
danny D'Amico audio mixer robin fenders
hair and makeup nikka geneva production
assistant ryan love the michael knowles
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 20 if you prefer
facts over feelings aren't offended by
the brutal truth and you can still laugh
at the insanity filling our national
news cycle well tune in to the ben
shapiro show we'll get a whole lot of
that and much more see you there